pat you bring up a great point i'm not
sure if you uh uh you're cutting in and
out but we
you bring up a great point about um
what china is doing behind closed doors
because
the second that we left
afghanistan i said on one of the
podcasts i said short term this is not a
good look but long term this allow us to
at least
turn our focus on to what really matters
which is china no doubt i mean i think
we were in afghanistan way too long we
could have got out of there five ten
years ago and been in a way better
position saved a trillion dollars
and
we should have turned our attention to
china whether you like trump or don't
like trump he at least
rattled the cage of china and woke up a
lot of the american public to say hey
what the hell is going on here in china
so
if there is conversations taking
taking place behind closed doors between
china and russia you brought up the
example of
you know getting your ex-girlfriend back
russia trying to get ukraine back and
china getting taiwan back
i'm actually proud or happy to see that
that biden is not getting into a war of
words or
literal hot war
over ukraine he's come out and he's
expressed we will not be sending troops
to fight in ukraine we're backing up
nato that's fine i think at the end of
the day
you think this is going to be a
short-lived situation short-lived war
whether that's weeks whether that's
months what have you
we cannot afford to take our eye off the
prize our eye off the ball of what is
happening with china and as much as
china is an enemy
we can't
you know not have them work with us on
certain things i.e climate change or
whether it's trade or not they're one of
our largest trading partners if not the
largest so this is a delicate line that
biden needs to balance and ukraine yes
it's a major thing it might be a blip on
the radar but he can't let that
affect
our relationship with china
you have thoughts on this tyler well and
that's the big ticket right it's china
is and i mean this is opening the door
for taiwan right i mean this taiwan is
is next on the table so
at what point does biden actually step
up and say no you cannot expand your
borders like this because this i mean
it's reminiscent of world war ii
world war ii when uh when hitler invaded
poland i mean these these dictators and
autocrats they get more and more and
more emboldened when we when we pulled
out of afghanistan like you said adam
the first person to swoop in was china
and to sign a deal and and you know they
now have 87 billion dollars worth of
military equipment which normally
wouldn't be a problem to
afghanistan and the taliban operating it
but what i worry about is it being
reverse engineered by the chinese and by
the russians and by them being able to
build military weapons that can match
ours so at what point does biden have to
step in and stop letting these dictators
and autocrats become more and more
emboldened
look let me read this to you here's an
article from the boston globe okay how
the u.s brought china and russia
together okay two generations ago
president nixon realized that the
intensifying partnership between moscow
and beijing could ultimately threaten
the u.s to prevent that he launched what
turned out to be a spectacularly
successful effort to disrupt their
partnership now we are doing the
opposite pushing china and russia
together
this month the leaders of the two
eurasian behemoths signed a far-reaching
joint statement that may end up shaping
the 21st century the interstate
relations between russia and china are
superior to political and military
alliance alliances of the cold war era
friendship between the two states has no
limits the implications of this accord
are daunting to contemplate especially
now with russia attacking ukraine even
though the us
remains the world's most powerful
country it's disconcerting to see the
two next most powerful countries joining
together that's what i was talking about
earlier worst of all we brought it on
ourselves bashing china and russia for
years was certain to turn them into
partners at some point it just happened
the world turned russian president
vladimir putin and chinese leader
chinese leader ji ching bing signed the
joint statement at the elaborate uh
ceremony before the opening of the
winter olympics in beijing this just
happened
that they pledged to promote
redistribution of power
in the world and specifically to support
each other's foreign policy priorities
for russia an end to nato expansion and
for china reunification from taiwan with
taiwan as the new china-russia
partnership was being unveiled putin
called it a relationship that will
probably
cannot be compared to anything in the
world and i agree
for americans to ignore it would be
foolish continuing to antagonize the
immense bloke
would be even worse if we cannot
accommodate the changing world it may
leave us behind so look whether this guy
who's got an opinion here to say let's
not say anything bad about them you have
to be naive to not stand up to the enemy
either and just kind of look the other
way you cannot do that i don't think you
can seem weak in a position in a
situation like this
but u.s has got to kind of get some
powerful
you know other countries to come with us
to go up against these guys because
these are the two
i don't know how to explain this these
are
it's it's it's the ultimate powerhouse
super team being put together except
it's two countries two of the top three
countries in the world are coming
together so
this is a real plan the world has to pay
very close attention to this let's let's
play that game for a second i mean we
just saw the the nba all-star game as an
example it was team
lebron versus team
durant and they had basically a draft
right uh lebron picked giannis first and
then durant picked um
embiid so on and so forth so if you're
having a a worldwide draft of countries
and china and russia align
who else is major that is on their side
because if you look at the list
uss canada the uk france italy basically
everyone in the eu
brazil australia japan
south korea you go down the list bang
bang bang bang bang u s other than china
and russia
would have all the heavyweights on their
team what other heavyweights are on team
china russia who iran who else like if
you're doing this draft who else is on
their side
all the true believers are on each
other's side
you have to realize a lot of the other
guys are more vanilla not saying we're
vanilla in america look at america right
now americans are at each other's throat
america in the last couple years during
covet while during 9 11 we united during
covet we were divided
because rather than making china the
enemy
you know democrats may trump the enemy
and that divided america
that made democrats hate republicans
republicans say democrats not everybody
but it became that antagonistic dinners
were being canceled because family
members couldn't have a basic civil
conversation together but why because we
were at each other's throat
when's the last time you heard about uh
media and china that they're at each
other's throats
how about in iran how about in russia
those three countries
no
they don't allow media in china or
or in iran
you're not but you're talking about
three countries
that hate
america
they hate america and they keep
recruiting other countries that also
hate america
so
this this next phase
this next phase
the concern i have with the system that
we have in america is
each president comes with a different
agenda and it changes every four to
eight years so we can't really create a
lot of momentum
there's a lot of division there's it's
hard to create momentum to create a
unified enemy while the other guys keep
their enemies unified so
anyways look i'm always optimistic about
what the future looks like because i
think the american people have overcome
a lot of different challenges all i'm
saying is the next 15 moves
america makes has to be very
we have to be united on this issue
it would be great to see trump and biden
right now
in this issue coming together
it would be great to see a lot of our
leaders in u.s coming together saying
hey
look we don't agree on taxes we don't
agree on xyz we don't agree we don't
even like each other but we love america
more than we love our ego and we won't
let you know america is more important
to us in china russia ukraine anybody
else
this is our land first we love this
country this is the greatest country in
the world
america needs something like that to
scare the crap out of everybody else out
there but america right now keeps
getting weaker and weaker and weaker
because we don't look united
[Music]